I think for the physics educators I
would suggest and to introduce the kind
of big question we are trying to solve
in the very beginning of the lecture
then people will come in and to your
lecture and annoying that we are trying
to solve this specific question then we
work on the theoretical calculation
using our physics intuition and physical
laws we learn from other class to solve
this question and then we check if we
have answered the big question which we
actually introduced in the beginning and
finally I would like to say that I would
like to stress that comparison between
cellular calculation and the demo is
very very important okay because that
gives you a chance to verify your
theoretical assumption to see if our
calculation actually making sense and
finally I usually summarize the kind of
take-home message or the conclusion from
this course so that people can work out
over classroom and knowing that this is
actually what they learn from this
lecture so actually I think that
essentially a pre capo to all kinds of
different physics course if we actually
try to do that way then that would make
the physics course much more enjoyable
in general teaching a course the
lecturers to show that he is so
interested in this course it is true
when the chorus when the lecturer I she
knows about the course very well and
knows the excitement about this course
very well so why don't you just show it
right because that will excite a lot of
interest from this when the students in
the classroom and also that will make
your lecture much more enjoyable not
only for the students but also for
yourself because you feel really happy
when you teach in the classroom